In this video, I will be explaining what Discrete
Mathematics is, and why it's important for
the field of Computer Science and Programming.
Discrete Mathematics is a branch of mathematics
that deals with discrete or finite sets of
elements rather than continuous or infinite
sets of elements.
Imagine trying to run a program that requires
an infinite number of executions to complete
a task.
It's obvious to say, that the program would
run forever and the task would never be completed
because there is an infinite number of executions.
In order to avoid this problem, we approximate
the continuous sets with discrete sets.
Now you may be thinking, I never use math
that involves infinite sets, but I promise
that you do.
The simplest example is with a circle.
A circle by definition is an infinite number
of points equally distant from a fixed point.
The problem with this is that if we try to
write a program that prints out all of these
points, it will run forever because there
is an infinite number of points and therefore
an infinite number of executions.
So, this is physically impossible, that's
why if we zoom in here, you can see that when
you come down here, there is all these points,
but in reality we should have even more points
between these points.
And if we zoom in on those, we should have
more points between those points, and we can
never complete the task.
Now we've all seen circles on computers, how
is this possible, because we just established
that it's impossible.
The answer is, is that there is approximations.
For example, consider regular polygons.
Regular Polygons, like a triangle, or a square,
or a pentagon.
They don't really look like circles.
However, if you keep increasing the number
of vertices.
Eventually you will get hexagons, octagons,
decagons, hexadecagons, icosagons.
You can see that these regular polygons, the
more and more you increase the number of vertices,
which the vertices are equally distant from
a fixed point, they will eventually approximate
a circle, and eventually they will be indistinguishable
to the naked eye and will look identical to
a circle.